le
rêve c'était plus clair qu'un souvenir
et j'ai entendu le bruit des
maisons tonitruantes brisant des boucliers et des épées sonnantes
et j'ai placé mes cheveux sur le
trône de fer
et tous les dragons ont rugi comme un seul
je considère la question urgente celle de
votre succession
ou de qui d'autre  aurait une prétention le
premier-né
renera aucune reine n'a jamais assis le
front de fer
le roi a un héritier damon targaryen je
ne serai pas obligé de choisir entre mon
frère et ma fille
[musique]
la succession de ronira sera contestée des
couteaux sortiront
[musique  ]
tu es le roi
ton devoir est de prendre une nouvelle épouse
j'ai décidé de nommer un nouvel héritier je suis
ta main la
guerre
est un pied
tu penses que le royaume m'acceptera jamais
comme cette reine
une femme n'hériterait pas du
trône de fer  parce que c'est l'ordre des
choses
quand je serai reine je créerai un nouvel ordre
ession
je dois hériter du trône de fer
elle me bloquera le chemin